pour la rencontre c'est à paris chez
jean n'avait remonté au aussi à
développer son projet cermak qui est
devenu plus tard le sermac une image
l'image c'est dans le 15ème
arrondissement saisir dans un parc en
train de lire en guise mon président le
mans une oeuvre les cahiers de retour au
pays natal
lorsque ça c'est vraiment pour moi une
fondatrice avec un triptyque enfermement
évasion en vol et puis je dirais côté
missionnaire de saisir le la statue de
cm ce qui nous a permis de faire le fait
de faire confiance à des jeunes comme
nous à l'époque pour lancer
véritablement ce grand projet pour
perpétuer cette identité martiniquais
qui nous est si cher pour moi en tant
que plasticien
c'est une richesse insoupçonnable 7e et
avant moi de plomb vraiment exploité
comme rené corail comme du major joseph
mais alors même un peu plus loin
françois wilfredo lam à cuba donc c'est
toute cette richesse qui est qui est
assemblé dans une oeuvre surréaliste et
qui nous permet de nous exprimer en
partant des racines parce que les
racines sont fondamentales